Canadians have won just two of seven games on the
road so far this season Suzuki comes up with a
loose Puck and it's tipped right on to Gibson
then had to make a secondary save Justin Baron
another former Colorado property he snaps it down
low off the Stick of Gallagher in behind the that
trying to redirect that one as it pops to the high
slot slap ksky has it again he finds a wide open
new hook and he SCS the penalty had expired and
Anaheim failed to get the puck out of the zone as
a result the Canadians have the first goal and
they draw a lot of penalties they come close
to surviving this it's not a power play goal but
for all intense and purposes at ease and Bo what
a quick pass to new hook and he didn't waste
any time look where that puck goes High over
the Blocker of John Gibson Gibson and the early
going is has already faced half a dozen shots make
it seven as that one Ricochet off of his gear
as it was petta who got it on net the Toronto
just gets it across the Blue Line Jake Evans gets
it back here comes yonan with it looking for gie
scores the defenseman jumps into the play and
the Canadians have come out to a flying start
amazingly professional young defenseman and
boy he's got good skills good instincts watch
this pass across as he jumps into the play and
that was just a beautiful feat across to gy he
just had to tap it into the wide open net Jesse
yonan with the pass and for gouie Canadians win
the puck to borak able to shovel it out and here
comes Coffield with speed his shot fought off by
the glove hand of John Gibson and Suzuki's pass
off Escape Lon can't find it and it's poked back
further into the Zone by mat Monahan and in front
Point length save by Gibson on Suzuki and as the
rebound came across Coffield played it but it was
knocked down by a high sticken looks up looks off
the four Checker and now puts it into the middle
of the ice Carlson rumbles in Terry great pass
across better save by monmo on color trading and
he's just going to Dish it off here to Troy Terry
and Troy Terry spots color coming late and what
a stop who what a great save good angle there
guys the Blocker of montmo that gets across
to absolutely Rob Alex colog five plus years
ago they game an 8year contract and it was moved
around a bit as you pointed out here's a rebound
for monteno that Henrik gets to with less than
5 Seconds to go on the period big Saves by the
Canadians net Miner taken away on a little hook
but is able to keep moving forward with it now
Jones behind the net loses is a puck battle
to Baron it comes to the line and it's fired
right on rebound given up by monmo in comes
Henri to poke it Loose no stick John for mono
and he makes two good stops Mavish leans in to
take the draw and wins it cleanly mof across the
top pass redirected in by Mavis great pass by Leo
Carlson well a couple of things to keep an eye on
first of all the job that McTavish does after the
draw to get inside of his check watch Mavis going
to win the draw rolls off it gets up and watch
him get that stick down on the ice what a pass
by Leo Carlson and Ducks fans get used to this
combination Mavish from Carlson and mikov on the
power play Carlson's got great vision Gallagher
again the veteran sweeps it to the line Baron
shot wide off the boards Coral by Suzuki Nick
Suzuki protects the puck to the line mat right
down Main Street he scores shot and the Canadians
get it right back just 52 seconds after the Ducks
got on the board I mean he got a lot on this but
this comes from long range Suzuki does a good job
protecting the puck spots him here Bo I don't know
does it hit bakan it looks like new hook takes a
poke at it I think it just goes in petta nudges
ahead for Evans he swaps it the rest of the way
and luno back to get it met by pizetta he just
misses the hit and swings it around the boards
patrono on it sneaks around the defender Frank to
the front of the neet great pass Mavis he scores
what a great individual effort by Frank patrono
McTavish with the Finish beautiful little feet to
McTavish all the way back from the duck Zone Earth
stro wins a battle to make sure the D can't get
it but all of a sudden Frank patrono boy he just
races pass kic gets the puck spins it out front
Alan had come over and left his check McTavish
Mason McTavish this one of his favorite spots
is just to go five hole on goenda Zone and go for
a change you can tell when a player is feeling it
though and the Ducks get it to the front of the
net Johnston had a crack at the rebound strubel
making his NHL debut out there right now with
gustoff Lindstrom who was recalled earlier this
month from Laval and here's Henri busting and
he goes back hand off the outside of the goal
post finally just flipping it out as Justin Baron
knocked down at Center by Leo Carlson he CHS back
in Leo on his off Wing fought off by Mono one
one handed back on net by color with the catching
glove gets it off the heel of the hand and can't
control Itor got a one-handed poke at him you know
really got some familiarity with him by playing
against him five or six times he won that one but
it went off nikov skate shot from the line doesn't
get through from mat then right through the goal
Pras Suzuki had a stab at it Fowler turns looks
up ice and uses the boards indirect to find a
man ahead on the play it's m a should the Tron
to ro by the glob hand of mon Mo what a stop
what an unbelievable stop feated Honda Center
because they thought this was going [Applause]
in now Elia has it right side his pass taken
by Mavis goes around a couple Defenders he's
in big save mon ball luno again reverses it
Fowler behind the net awaits pressure and
now nice pass up the left side and McTavish
takes a rink wide feed pulls up on the dot
looking for a trailer leaves it there it's
vrono score oh what a shot it's a brand new
game on Mason McTavish catching this puck right
there Rolling Puck settles it down throws on the
brakes Shields it and drops it off and boy Frank
patrono he does not have much room up top look
at this he's got maybe a 6 in square up top over
the shoulder of montmo and he hits it with just an
absolute [Applause] snipe Monahan to Pearson and
now Tanner Pearson changing directions brings it
in front nice job by Gibson who poke checked it
away oh wow what a save by Gibs 40 seconds left
in the four on four three and A2 the goal in the
game mikov races to Center across the line looks
around tried to drop it back and that's taken away
Evans beat McTavish to it Evans for new hook he
[Applause] scores and here's the turnover and
the two-on-one break and Off to the Races watch
this pass it's the second time the new hooks
just got a beautiful pass Montreal executes
on the two-on-one 15 seconds left Troy peels
off the boards wants to bring it to the middle
forced to the corner got it to McTavish drops it
off here's a shot from mnov didn't get through
McTavish had a stick on it for a moment Terry out
of the corner with 3 seconds left has it knocked
away and as it swept the length of the ice it
goes in in the empty net I don't know if it
went in before the clock went to zeros but either
way the Canadians will get the win here tonight